[Music]
first Wonder Woman on film
famously there was a TV show but some
various TV incarnations but you're the
first one on film for you to see
everything and we have actually an image
here of you as the character you look at
they're dealing with comic book fans who
are very loyal but they're also very
intense they right away got into
critiquing things about during your look
yeah what is your read what did you hear
I some people I think were and this is
actually true there were comments that
they wanted like oh we want her to be
more bosomy that was a bigger heart
bigger heart yeah yeah that's I'm
talking about frustrated nerds online I
think you look absolutely stunning
here they take it dinner anytime I have
a husband but I don't have a boyfriend
yes oh good
yes they were they were some people who
had a lot to say about my heart and and
and you know at the end of the day you
can't please them all right and I
completely understand that and if you
want to be original to the story
the Amazons used to have only one breast
because it was in the way with the arc
with the arch and the error is that true
be real they only had one breast it was
in the middle to let him shoot a bone
and we had been where was the brass deal
with it later it's okay keep going
you're doing great that has these little
talks with me every now and then where
he explains that I'm confused I'm so
confused so eventually after many
creative conversations with Zack we
decided to keep them both and good call
you